if we told our two-dimensional friend
that infinitely many circles stacked
together in the third dimension makes a
sphere they would find that hard to
imagine I've spoken a big game about the
fact that a four-dimensional hypersphere
is made out of infinitely many 3D
spheres but how exactly are the Spheres
join together in the fourth dimension
well your guess is as good as mine one
idea is that the Spheres are stacked
together like a string of pearls on a
necklace but that idea doesn't make a
whole lot of sense because the string
would need to be infinitely long to
contain all the Spheres of varying size
and besides doing that with circles
isn't what makes us fear so it's time to
go back to the drawing board